Wall Street Journal reporting in May a
couple months ago Ron Paul ads warned of
a financial crisis former representative
Ron Paul is warning in television
commercials of a calamitous us financial
crisis that could bring civil unrest and
a stock market collapse a crash
infinitely worse than the crisis of 2008
he urges viewers to prepare by buying a
survival blueprint a book advice from an
investment research firm Ron Paul has
been appearing in radio spots web videos
and television ads for Stansberry and
associates investment research a
Baltimore firm whose founder Porter
Stanbury was once sued by the Securities
and Exchange Commission for fraud
arising from stock tips sold through his
newsletter the ads urged viewers to buy
a book by mr. Stansbury American 2020
America 2020 the survival blueprint to
safeguard savings and wealth against the
crisis it says will arise from the
devaluation of the dollar driven by the
Federal Reserve's loose money policies
and the federal debt stocks and bonds
will crash the 79 year old former Texas
Congress congressman says in an ad
broadcast on CNN the savings of millions
could be wiped out you can't rely on
Washington to help you the doomsday
warnings aren't entirely different from
views Ron Paul expressed as a member of
Congress and presidential candidate when
he called for a return to the gold
standard abolishing the Fed and other
libertarian policies to change the
status quo but the nationally broadcast
ads are a high-profile reminder of how
far his views are from those of
mainstream economists most of whom are
projecting slow but steady growth for
the US the SEC Stu neither mr. Stansbury
nor Ron Paul responded requests for the
comment on the ads the SEC sued mr.
Stansbury for fraud concerning stock
tips sold to newsletter subscribers mr.
Stanbury
fought the charges in court while with
the support of some newspapers saying it
was a violation of First Amendment
rights of free speech Supreme Court last
fall declined to hear the case after a
lower court ruled against mr. Stansbury
so why did I read that because I don't
do politics much on this show and I'm
certainly not here to pick on Ron Paul
and it's Ron Paul not Rand Paul his son
is the ones running for for president so
it's not about any of that and I don't
know anything about Stansbury I know as
much about them as you do right now
because I just now read this article to
you and I'm not an expert on those guys
but I do know that in the last few weeks
an increasing number of emails are
coming in this place and an increasing
number of calls are coming in to our
customer care center wanting to know how
to prepare for the end of the world
financial collapse that apparently is
predicted for September by some of these
people there's a book called the
harbinger out that has some of that in
it and I think it was I think that there
may have may have been a year off but I
think the Mayans predicted the end of
the world last year but of course
there's not a lot Mayans around to make
the argument because apparently their
predictions about a lot of things is
wrong so so let me help you guys okay
you do whatever you want to do but I I'm
an evangelical Christian I believe the
Bible and the Bible says that fear is
not a fruit of the Spirit well I look
around to Haven I see Wars and I see
Greece collapsing and I see you know us
capitulating or negotiating or whatever
you call it with Iran
I see the stock market going up it's
artificially high its artificially low I
see real estate booming I see I can't
tell and I I'm just scared I understand
I understand that means you're watching
the news too much you need to turn off
your television I have a friend of mine
watching CNN and Fox all day long we're
going to have to put the boy in a rubber
room
it's going to destroy his psyche
Zig Ziglar used to say I get up every
morning and read the newspaper and read
the Bible to see what both sides are
doing so I mean really you you you have
got to think about what you're putting
in your brain and one of the downsides
of 24-hour news is that it's not good
none of it and I participate in it I
show up on CN occasionally I show up on
Fox occasionally but it's not the
predicting of the world
so fatiguing so here's the thing I'm 50
almost 55 years old be 55 next month and
I have seen the end of the world
predicted pretty regularly through all
throughout my adult life there was gonna
be the thing under the grace Commission
under Reagan there's a whole thing about
the hockey stick graph of the debt and
how that was going to cause the you know
there was a banker a book out by the
grace Peter Grace who was the head of
the grace Commission under Reagan to
study the national debt and they
predicted it was called bankruptcy in
1984 it was predicting the bankruptcy
the United States in 1984 because the
debt was going to surpass our ability to
carry it guess he missed that one maybe
he meant a different 1984 no he didn't
he just predicted the end of the world a
couple years later I got a brochure in
the mail from Christian people in this
same area 88 reasons Jesus is coming
back in 88 it must have been another
reason because you missed something he
didn't come back in 88 I mean you know
the end of the world is possible but not
likely because they just remade the
movie Mad Max that right there is a
direct indicator where do you people get
this information truthfully it's like we
are a Freudian or something and we
really expect bad things to happen by
the way when you start taking actions
based on expecting bad things to happen
you pretty much ensure the bad things
are going to happen in your life so if
you sell everything and move to a
log-cabin because of the predictions of
the end of the world
hope you like log cabins you're gonna be
there a while it's not that I'm
just eternally optimistic or that I've
got my head in the sand and I don't
admit that there's problems with the
debt in the US and spending by Congress
and this out-of-control president that
has spent more than all the other
presidents in history put together it's
not got anything to do with any of that
yes that's all stupid and yes that all
needs to be fixed but please people
don't sell everything you own liquidate
your IRAs and go buy generators water oh
did I mention y2k you missed that one
too didn't you still got any of your
dried food so I mean really if you run
your life based on fear of what might
happen you are going to ruin your life
there is no biblical indication that
this is going to occur but in fact a lot
of biblical indications that the world
is not coming to an end in September
matter of fact you can just call me up
in October and tell me I was wrong the
war I will give you a prediction I very
seldom do that but I will give you a
firm prediction that the world will not
come to an end the financial markets are
not going to collapse in September I am
NOT pulling money out of the stock
market I'm not liquidating my real
estate and I'm not pulling money out of
the banks stop being cult following
children America this is stupid